hello colleagues students and Friends
I hope you're having a wonderful start
to the fall semester
as I Was preparing for the new Academic
Year which is my 11th as president
I reflected on all that we've achieved
together over the past decade
and I considered when would be a good
time for a leadership transition here at
Yale
of course we have so much more to do so
there really is no perfect time for one
but right now we are a strong University
and we've built momentum for even
greater achievement in the years ahead
so I decided that this will be my last
year as president I will step down from
the role on June 30th 2024 unless
additional time is needed to choose a
successor
I will return to research writing and
eventually teaching in the Hills
Department of psychology
so you will certainly see me around
campus
of course it's been an honor and a
privilege to serve our University and
Community after all I've been here for
42 years
and I'm profoundly proud of the progress
we have made to advance Yale's mission
of Education research scholarship
preservation and practice
we've added over 2.2 million square feet
of stunning and functional space for
research and teaching including the
humanities quadrangle Yale science
building Klein Tower Peabody Museum two
new residential colleges the Schwartzman
Center and so much more
we've transformed and are continuing to
transform Science Hill enhanced
multi-disciplinary scholarship across
the university and created institutes
and centers for research in the
humanities Sciences social science and
engineering
we launched the Jackson School of global
Affairs we are transitioning the Yale
School of Public Health and the School
of Engineering and applied science into
Independent Schools
at the same time we've fostered a
greater culture of innovation good
examples are the creation of Yelp
Ventures and Thai City and we've
nurtured increased International
Partnerships through the Yale Africa
initiative and other faculty-led
collaborations worldwide
and here at home we've established
university-wide efforts on inclusion
diversity and belonging
this year we will finish a project
focused on understanding Yale's
historical roles in an associations with
slavery
meanwhile we strengthen Partnerships
with and financial support for our home
City
creating opportunities for inclusive
growth
we also have expanded The Faculty across
the university and we've improved the
Excellence and breadth of Faculty
research and scholarship
and the student body doesn't look at all
like it did a decade ago it is now even
more promising and diverse across every
Dimension thanks to Greater
affordability for undergraduate graduate
and Professional School students
for example we expanded the
undergraduate student body by 15 percent
and doubled the number of Pell Grant
eligible and first generation college
students
along the way we've raised over five
billion dollars through the four
Humanity campaign toward the seven
billion dollar goal and I'm not going to
stop fundraising even after returning to
the faculty
you can read more about what we have
accomplished together over the past 10
years in the accompanying Yale news
story
of course our work is not done
we have a busy year ahead
and I look forward to working with you
on research and educational programs and
initiatives that support faculty
students staff and alumni
and we will continue to move ahead on
the planned investments in various
schools and units such as the expansion
of Faculty facilities projects whether
in planning or construction phases
throughout the University
partnership with the City of New Haven
and well-being and belonging initiatives
in the meantime I want to thank you for
your partnership over the years and for
your commitment
to Yale
foreign